I think this has got to be the whitest
richest richest whitest crime ever these
[ __ ] celebrities okay it's I'm gonna
bring it up real quick all right it's
Lori Loughlin Lori Loughlin and she she
was let me bring it up [ __ ] she was
uh what's her face in full house and
then in fuller house I mean her daughter
is like a youtuber you can look up her
face Lori laughs mo and Felicity Huffman
okay okay so they this is crazy
they got charged in with a federal
federal indictment okay because they
were involved in this giant like
conspiracy to get their kids into
colleges that they couldn't get into so
basically what they did is they paid
they do they paid this guy that ran like
a like um was called a like a tutoring
service or something oh really he was
just like a con artist I was really good
at getting people into schools they paid
him fifteen million dollars to get their
kids into a USC and like other schools
by by bribing coaches in the school to
say that the kid is an athlete and that
they were gonna get recruited so that
they flagged their application no not
only that but they also cheated on the
SATs on the AC T's you cheat on those
tests I know they had like other kids
take them for them or something this is
a whole like [ __ ] scheme it's crazy
[ __ ] so they're kicking go to USC which
even that goin oh my god dude oh my god
dude they had bait this is funny what
in one case okay here much of the
indictment revolves around William Rix
singer the founder of a for-profit
College counseling and preparation
business known as the key as laid out in
the indictment singer allegedly paid
college coaches to claim that a
prospective student should be accepted
to college because the student was a
recruit for their sports team
however singer and the coaches knew that
the student was not have competitive BOA
in one case singer even worked with
parents to take stage
photos of their child engaged in
particular sports in another example
they use stock photos of a person
playing a sport and then put the face of
the student onto the pathway Photoshop
well I don't even photoshopping your
kids face on a soccer plan I don't even
feel bad for the schools for accepting
that [ __ ] because if they got they
really got duped by some but that's what
did it for him not even the coaches look
look he's playing to get that I don't
like a stock picture with the watermarks
on yeah okay that's face photoshopped
over it's like this is actually this is
clearly a dude's body yeah if the if
that's how it looks the judge just has
to reverse the whole thing's everybody
you know what what they did was bad but
it's worse that you fell for that I'm
gonna just say not guilty man you y'all
some dumbass y'all some whole idiots out
here that's that is the whitest [ __ ]
ever I mean it's just like I thought if
you were rich you can just donate a ton
to the school and they'd accept your kid
isn't that the way that [ __ ] works I
thought yeah usually
yeah they paid this dude 20 like this
your kids must be [ __ ] dumb yeah just
dumb as nails dumb as nails if I don't
how much say it's like we made me wat
you I see a building you're still not
gonna accept my child nah sorry my
stupid
that's so Wow what do you even say to
that what do you even say to that it's
crazy I mean it's like it's just the
stupid it's like what a dumb [ __ ]
crime the most privileged crime ever
yeah like what are you also funneling
money through your yoga studios or
something yeah that's that's so wild it
reminds me of weeds or something it's a
totally you know totally I would have
thought Lori Loughlin and Felicity
Huffman are now federal criminals the
problem you know we [ __ ] up if they
did more time in 69 [ __ ] up yep they
like actual time and oh no dude she
snitches on all the other all the other
moms moms then they start a reality show
inside the federal prison
the real moms of yeah the real moms of
Club fed just like totally there this is
my giving well Cynthia told me she would
share her ramen noodles with me
yesterday and now she's not going to
yeah so I'll have a word with her about
that Lori got less time because she's
been running this [ __ ] yoga class in
the mornings for all the other inmates
is not even good it's like her body yeah
I get it Yahoo she's in great shape for
being 45 but whatever it's not that good
okay I could easily do that class um I'm
sorry Susan were you just talking [ __ ]
about my class no no me no no Lori come
on we're besties besties you know that
were Fetty besties it's fine that you
run a average yoga class when we all
know Bikram Yoga is the way to go
wait two things about one of our prison
what about passive aggression one so
Martin shkreli dis muhfucka yeah what's
the deal with that I didn't I couldn't
read the article because it was [ __ ]
locked yeah The Wall Street Journal ya
know the if you wait a little X pops up
and then you can close it no way
so basically he um it appears that he's
advising his pretty like his prior to
accompany from prison via cellphone yeah
and they're saying that well you're not
allowed to run a business or like earn
money while like in prison so you can't
conduct business while in prison that's
what it is okay so the things are gonna
nail him for more time for you know
basically telling them how to run the
company
why would because I feel like they they
interviewed him didn't they
to get that article I don't know I
didn't I only got as far as that and
that he kind of roams around with like
two cronies and that's about it
oh and he um he was gonna join a band in
prison supposedly but the band was made
up of pedophiles all right so his two
homies like don't do that and I guess
it's crazy the way they winds have to
tell you not to do that well why
wouldn't you just be like I'm not gonna
join this band well the way the way it's
worded makes it seem like he was still
gonna do it but I take it with a grain
of salt man because you know some
articles were written about us yeah and
the sensationalization was crazy yeah
you know so I don't know
oh especially but like with him though I
feel like that's nothing is too weird
with that yeah that dudes [ __ ] weird
yeah but they can get away with it and
be like man they're just like they were
writers room for it yeah what if you
want to join a pan full of pedophiles
yeah yeah yeah the lead singer is
six-nine what if Martin gives 6:9 the
wu-tang album just the instrumentals and
6:9 raps
covers them on the wu-tang the new woof
wu-tang album in this timeline dude
nothing would surprise me now like that
no weird [ __ ] like that happens every
day
[Music]